so I guess to start off you know alwa
Dumbo what is the worst nickname you've
ever been given or called Oh God I've
had a few cruel ones back in the day
when I was a kid I actually used to call
me Dumbo because I'm here so this is
very G I know you've got larger than
normal air spell gorgeous topic today
they're so meek I know he's so cruel
kids are the worst they can be so so
cruel I had a few you know the the
crudest things that were said to me were
in relation to my my brother sexuality
my brother's gay nation yes so I was I
was called the same derogatory words
that he was called for his sexuality I
was called and that not only because
it's just horrible to hear the venom
that stuff can be spit towards you with
I also knew it was in reference to him
so I was feeling a double thing you know
so yeah kids how do you deal with that
sort of persecution or that at the time
he tells me I don't remember he says I
got in a few fights at the time I don't
know but sometimes he just had to take
it on the chin I know you know people's
cruelty comes from them it's it's it's
it's very little if anything to do with
the person that the cruelty is inflicted
upon it's all to do unfortunately that
doesn't make things better in the moment
but when someone fixed cruelty on
another it's all to do with them sadly
the way we are the person who the
cruelty inflicted upon has to experience
the consequences and sometimes the
consequences is just hurting you know
feeling pain and sadness and
disappointment in isolation hope is a
character that's dealing with a lot of
trauma in this movie but he's also like
a family film so I'm interested in
opening for you what is that balance
between planes sort of the gravitas of
the character versus this sort of tone
this family well the rather kind of Sara
note we start to develop what I was just
saying before that all those themes and
all those cruelties and that sense of
isolation and not belonging and all that
is in the film but the beautiful thing
is that the is that in the film it's not
some wish fulfillment or it shows you a
world that doesn't exist that it is
possible for decency for kindness for
inclusion and for patience to prevail
against the more negative aspects of the
human condition and how it expresses
itself so at its core this film has
has a kind of a very real and very
detectable and and and feelable
sweetness to it
so if it was just yeah if it was just
all the other stuff and there was no way
out but it does have an uplifting ending
which is beautiful again is possible
because I think you know our better
aspects can confront and can defeat our
worst aspects but we have to decide that
that's where we want to live you know
and I think that that's one of the
beautiful things about this film is it
is kind of the force of darkness against
the force of light you know and light
prevails
I mean double is sort of the ultimate
example of this sort of character taken
for granted yeah when you were starting
out as an actor did you ever have to
deal with that being taken for granted
no I mean I hadn't really no I mean
undervalued you know the biggest the
biggest concern for any of us whether we
realize it or not is you know we'd say
it's I'm not valued by the world when
the world's value or the word the value
of the world puts on you wouldn't matter
so much if one knew has a value one self
sure so nobody has ever been able to be
as cruel to me as I could be to myself
ever ever ever and with that said I had
a very greased part at the circuit of
all this you know 20 odd years ago yeah
I really did I went to theater school
and I had plenty of auditions I didn't
get called back for and all that kind of
stuff but from very early on I got I
caught a couple of breaks and I was very
very lucky was there ever a crisis of
confidence over struggles tried a couple
of minutes ago when I thought I brought
this whole interview screaming down you
know torrent of you know Self Indulgence
flames and making things about my school
days and how hard they were apart from
that no how do you sort of about how do
you deal with this sort of crisis of
confidence how do you get pie how do you
get by that uh he just he just just put
one foot in front of the other sometimes
you know I think just didn't as the
years go you know you just try to pretty
perhaps try to be you know less hard on
yourself and and and not expect less but
yeah ad live under less expectation you
know because the expectations we usually
put on ourselves are entirely from moss
they're from elsewhere you know usually
a lot of the time
you